[Music]
I'm saman Amira farming here in Weldon
West Otago with my wife Penny and three
children and we're farming 565 hectare
shaking beef property we're looking at a
wandering block here
we were wondering Frisian Bulls on Fatih
beat and I just looked at the way we're
grazing them really so that's what we're
here for today with the one to the
waders we really have to carry some feed
through from the summer into the winter
to be able to to get through and you
know product great and kale and winter
brassicas are a good good option just to
carry some quality right through and
especially for to beat with cattle we're
taking some good quality feed that they
can grow right through into October on
so it's been a real winner yeah Palmer
Hawk catchment project was started up
about three years ago and it's basically
a group of farmers all farmers sheep and
beef dairy in forestry and everybody all
got together and decided that we needed
to improve the polymer Hakka River
because it was labeled by the taga
Regional Council was the West River and
Otago so we thought well that's not
really good enough so we got together
and thought how we're gonna go about
improving it so we decided the best way
was to see what the problem was with a
lot of water testing and here so the
group started off tasting a lot of
trouble trees all the trouble trees the
main river as well and saw where the
problem was and found out that it wasn't
actually just a diri problem and it was
pretty much catchment wide so and that
was when we started doing some on-farm
water testing and here maybe being a
shape and be far more thorough it's not
my problem but when we started testing
on this place we found out that yeah
there was water quality issues here
might be different to the dairy industry
beware it was more sediment and
phosphorous but so that's why we've
needed to focus a bit more on winter
crops because that seems to be a Wikus
length with women we've got the best of
oil what we're doing is changing the way
we graze paddocks making sure we don't
let anything anywhere near any water
ways and when grazing paddocks from the
top down so that we can you know stop
the sediment ending up in the waterways
so grazing down the hill from top to
bottom where around what we're doing is
when the stock loosening up any soil and
there's a rainfall event the sediment
will come down the hill through the
break where it's been eaten through the
crop and then there'll be a grass buffer
before the waterway or the drain or the
critical source area but so the oval
cinnamon will get trapped before it gets
under the waterway so that's the that's
the crux of the grazing management with
the last breakers you're coming into the
wrapping up grazing the paddock with
your mob um you want to have a good
buffer zone of grass on a flat area
probably least 2 to 3 meters and on a
steep area maybe anything up to 20
meters and so the further back you go
the better but if your grazing late last
that last break an enjoy day preferably
or a dry couple of days so that there's
no seiderman
loss that's going to end up in the
waterway here when we're grazing the
paddocks you know top to bottom now
we're seeing it when we're coming down
the hill worm there's a rainfall event
the sediments actually flying through
the crop that's been grazed under the
leaft area that hasn't been grazed and
it stops there it's not even getting
into the grassed area so that's showing
us that it really does work yes I think
it's something that every farmer should
have docked initially especially with
cattle that's a no-brainer just to do
straightaway that there's you know real
gains to be made with stopping that
scene when there's a lot of storm has
been shown to be moving with cattle
grazing on when the crops with it all
that beer soil we're really vulnerable
in the winter so yeah you've just got to
get on and do it it's it's just stopping
that sediment right where it's where it
started rather than waiting for it to
come downstream that's been reasonably
easy it's just a change of mine see it
really where you're grazing them and
you've got something else to think about
you're not just thinking about water
troughs or we put them on the only
easiest gauge udders to get to it's a
matter of you know thinking about it a
year in advance and planning making sure
you've got water in the right place and
maybe putting up a couple of extra
electric fences to make sure that you've
can do it properly
[Music]